public health propaganda reached new
heights this past weekend
when brazilian authorities lit up the
very famous statue of christ the
redeemer
in rio de janeiro lit it up
in a line that says vaccine saves
very creepy extremely sacrilegious
and also just not true you know you know
how i know this
i know this with scientific certainty
100
of people who get the vaccine will die
i can i know that youtube's going to try
to shut me down for that
it is simply a scientific fact 100
of people who get the vaccine will die
now
they're probably not going to die
tomorrow very possibly the vaccine will
extend their lives but they will die
this substitute religion
is ridiculous and so many people these
days
are beginning to tune it out they are
realizing that the public health
establishment
has not only lost its credibility has
not only misled people in so many ways
but it is also grabbing so much power
that it does not deserve
political power and religious power as
well and many many people
are tuning it out people are beginning
to tune out
if they haven't already they're
certainly now beginning to tune out
the public health propagandists who are
taking a lot of power for themselves
notably eric clapton you know eric
clapton very famous one of the most
famous rock musicians in the world
eric clapton is saying things that could
get him kicked off of youtube
here's what he's saying i'm just going
to report what he's saying because if i
were to say it
i could run the risk of being kicked off
of youtube that is how closely
uh tied in the big tech industry is
with the bureaucracy with the government
with the public health administration so
i'm just going to read what eric clapton
said and his experience of the vaccine
he said quote
i took the first jab of astrazeneca and
right away had severe reactions which
lasted 10 days
i recovered eventually and was told it
could be 12 weeks before the second one
about six weeks later i was offered and
took the second astrazeneca shot but
with a little more knowledge of the
dangers
needless to say the reactions were
disastrous my hands and feet were either
frozen
numb or burning and pretty much useless
for two weeks
i feared i would never play again this
guy is one of the most famous guitarists
ever
you know in in popular music and so that
that's a very big fear he goes on
i suffer with peripheral neuropathy and
should never have gone near the needle
but the propaganda said the vaccine was
safe for everyone so here's the here's
the issue
okay i am not telling any tales at a
school here okay i'm not saying anything
that is a conspiracy theory or anything
like that remember they paused a vaccine
because there were rare rare rather but
significant
side effects only affected a very small
number of people
but they were very very as significant
as they possibly can be
and you're not really allowed to talk
about that even when the public health
officials come out and say yes there
have been these rare cases but
we're going to pause certain vaccines
but then we're going to start them again
we the public and especially
communicators are not allowed to mention
this or we're called conspiracy
theorists and we're
called anti-vaxxers or something and
taken off of the internet i'm
nothing of the sort and i'm not even
anti-vaccine
generally speaking but i do think we
should be able to report on these sorts
of reactions a lot of people
have heard these things anecdotally from
friends or relatives or friends of
friends or in this case
from eric clapton but we're not allowed
to do that
because the scientific matter of the
vaccines is not really considered a
scientific matter
just like the scientific matter of the
coronavirus is not really considered a
scientific matter
it's a political matter whereby public
health officials
will will lie to our faces right they'll
say one day they'll say
don't wear the masks the masks don't
work you shouldn't wear the mask you
stupid sheep
i'm paraphrasing or exalted dr fauci
then five seconds later he says
you have to wear the masks and then
later on he justifies it and says
that he misled us in the first place
because he thought that all of us
peasants would go out and buy up the
masks and he wanted to save them for the
nurses
but now that he knows there's enough
masks he's going to tell us that we need
to buy them
okay presuming to take a lot of
political power and in the case of rio
presuming to to take to take the place
of christianity
to supplant christianity in rio for
goodness sakes
and and on a very famous statue of
christ the redeemer a statute
that says christ saves to cover that up
and say no vaccine
saves which is to say the public health
officials
save if you do not ring that bell you
will pay the price i don't want to sound
too much like joe biden here but you
will the price you will pay is
you will not get notifications of our
new videos frankly you might not get the
notifications anyway
based on how youtube reacts to us a lot
of the time but to give yourself the
best shot
ring the bell like subscribe we'll see
you next time